[Música]
economía está aquí en el estudio de
directo américa jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches vamos a comenzar con una
noticia humanitaria la ayuda de varios
países a ucrania con motivo del
conflicto que está viviendo el g7 acordó
enviar 18 mil 400 millones de dólares
para ucrania para ayudarlos a pagar
precisamente sus facturas en los
próximos meses los ministros de finanzas
y los gobernadores de los bancos
centrales de eeuu japón canadá reino
unido alemania francia e italia se
reúnen mientras ucrania se queda sin
efectivo en medio de esta guerra la
comisión europea propuso también
entregar 9.000 millones de euros
adicionalmente en asistencia
macrofinanciera a ucrania este año los
ministros se reúnen en alemania
abordarán también la situación de la
economía global tras la pandemia y en el
contexto de un alza global de precios el
ministro de finanzas alemán christian
línder dijo que alemania concedería a
ucrania mil millones de euros y japón se
comprometió también a duplicar su ayuda
a ucrania hasta 600 millones de dólares
ucrania calcula que necesita unos 5 mil
millones de dólares al mes para mantener
el sueldo de los empleados públicos y el
funcionamiento de la administración el
g7 como sabrán es el grupo de países más
realizados del mundo y acumula más de la
mitad de la riqueza mundial jorge pero
con una economía colapsada y afectada
por el conflicto cuanto ha perdido
ucrania desde que comenzó la invasión
rusa según la escuela de economía de
kiev el país ha perdido unos 600.000
millones de dólares tras la invasión la
cifra que dan los investigadores
proviene del cálculo de los costos
directos de las infraestructuras
afectadas así como costos indirectos
como la disminución del producto interno
bruto las ayudas sociales y la pérdida
de inversión hay al menos 195 fábricas y
empresas 230 instituciones sanitarias y
900 40 centros educativos fueron dañados
destruido o incautado según este informe
el mayor costo ha sido en
infraestructuras como edificios
residenciales y carreteras la cifra
asciende en ese rubro a 60 mil millones
de dólares en pérdidas más de 540
guarderías 95 instituciones religiosas y
140 edificios culturales también fueron
afectados por esta guerra según el
estudio los daños a los activos
empresariales ucranianos ascendieron a
casi 10 mil millones de dólares
porque otro país que también tiene la
economía seriamente afectada de civil
blanca por la crisis política también
hay crisis económica y crisis de
suministro de combustibles la mayoría de
las gasolineras allí se quedaron sin
combustible la policía disparó gases
lacrimógenos y cañones de agua para
contener a cientos de universitarios
furiosos con el gobierno el gobernador o
el banco central dijo que habían
liberado los dólares necesarios para
pagar los envíos de combustible y gas
utilizando parte de los 130 millones de
dólares recibidos por el banco mundial
el nuevo primer ministro ya hizo
nombramiento en su gabinete pero aún no
designa a un ministro de finanzas el
banco central espera que la inflación
aumente hasta el 40% en los próximos dos
meses allí los precios de los alimentos
subieron un 46 6% con respecto a un año
la crisis de santiago comenzó con la
pandemia y se extendió hacia el turismo
un sector clave para esa economía el
aumento de los precios del petróleo y
los recortes fiscales del gobierno del
presidente go gotabaya rajapaksa y su
hermano más linda también avivaron el
descontento social que se vive la
economía se ha visto golpeada por los
precios subvencionados del combustible y
la decisión prohibir las importaciones
de fertilizantes químicos que daño al
sector agrícola este país entró en
default y dejó de pagar su deuda externa
a falta de recursos eso de default me
hace acordar algunos casos en américa
latina algunos incumplimientos en sus
pagos internacionales recordemos algunos
de esos casos bueno bloomberg en línea
recordó a los países de américa latina
que han caído en una situación similar
como argentina que tuvo que renegociar
su deuda con el fmi o ecuador en el año
2020 esto las empresas calificadoras de
riesgo lo consideran también un default
como lo que está pasando ahora mismo
decir que la ncaa en diversos periodos
de la historia estos son los países de
la región que más han caído en
incumplimiento de deuda en primer lugar
con más cantidad de años como deudor lo
ocupa honduras con 118 años acumulados
en deuda seguido de ecuador con 106 años
y nicaragua con 98 años el cuarto lugar
lo ocupa méxico en esta lista y pasamos
a abordar los indicadores como las
faldas principales bolsas en el día de
hoy empezamos en wall street que cerró
en rojo ya que persisten los temores de
una recesión inducida por la subida
tipos de interés de la reserva federal
de eeuu en europa las acciones se
desplomaron un 15 por ciento ampliando
los descensos a la segunda sesión
consecutiva y en américa latina la bolsa
mexicana de valores cerró en positivo y
se perfila para cerrar la semana con
algunos avances jorge muchas gracias por
este bloque informativo del mundo
económico es todo por el momento pero a
continuación el debate aquí en directo
américa siga con nosotros